Chop-Syc is an interactive cutting board with
built-in scale and measuring devices.
And this bench concept allows you to record
a video to the cloud while you sit on it which
is linked to the shadows cast by the bench
that can later be accessed with an augmented
reality app that reads the data from the appearance
of the shadows.
Vsauce!
Kevin here - this is Mind Blow.
IBM is working on a new computer prototype
fueled by electronic blood.
Using the human brain as a model, they're
designing them to be cooled and fueled by
a liquid just like the blood of a human brain.
This new system pumps an electrolyte blood
through a computer carrying power in and taking
heat out.
And they hope by 2060 a one petaflop computer
the size of half a football field today will
fit on your desktop.
The Neurocam is a wearable camera that automatically
records what interests you by analyzing your
brainwaves.
It works on a scale of 1 to 100 with a brain
wave sensor that connects to an iPhone.
If your interest exceeds 60, the phone will
automatically start recording to produce a
5 second animated GIF.
The future of this project is to create an
emotional interface that can use people's
thoughts and feelings for a wide range of
practical applications.
China's smog problem could be helped by a
new smog-devouring vacuum concept.
By using underground copper coils the smog
particles are attracted and brought down from
the atmosphere to the ground.
Recently in a lab setting they created a one
cubic meter smog free hole in a 5 by 5 meter
room, and the challenge is now to create it
on a larger scale for public spaces.
Dung Beetles gallop.
And it looks like this.
So Yeah.
The Aerial Imaging Plate displays interactive
images floating in the air.
Developed by Asukanet, the image is visible
at a specific certain angle so only the user
is able to see it which would make it safe
to use for ATM's.
And there are no fingerprint or hygiene concerns
since the user is not actually touching an
actual screen.
FlyKly is a smart wheel that significantly
upgrades an ordinary bike.
It has a pedal assist that's able to go up
to 20 mph for 30 miles and is used in conjunction
with an app.
The smart light attached to the handlebars
has a pad designed to hold your phone and
also charges it while you're riding.
The wheel locks with the touch of a button
and in case your bike is still stolen there's
GPS tracking sent directly to your phone and
it can also suggest alternate routes that
may be faster or just more fun.
The poppy project from INRIA flowers is trying
to create everyday personalized humanoid robots.
And even though it's not quite ready to walk
on its own, it was designed to better understand
biped locomotion and interactions between
humans and robots.
All of the parts for the robot will be able
to be 3D printed or purchased from an electronics
store, even though it may cost around $11,000
to make your own.
Cooler Cannon.
Star Path from Pro Teq is a spray-applied
elastometric coating that creates illuminated
paths at night.
The coating is applied in three layers and
only takes about half an hour to dry.
The middle layer absorbs UV energy during
the day and emits this blue glow when it gets
dark out.
The process can be applied to many surfaces
including stone paths, driveways, and even
playgrounds.
The Ivanpah Solar Electric Generating System
will be the largest solar thermal power tower
system in the world.
Located in the California desert, the amount
of carbon dioxide saved from going into the
atmosphere will be the equivalent of taking
70,000 cars off of the road and will generate
electricity for 140,000 homes.
Flirty is the first unmanned aerial vehicle
delivery technology.
Zookal dot com is an online textbook resource
delivering textbooks via a drone in Sydney,
Australia.
All you have to do is order from the app on
your smartphone and the book will be shipped
within minutes.
But currently commercial flights of UAVs are
not legal in the United States.
Finally Tribocycle created by Ben Ridgway
is a absolutely mesmerizing looping movie
for large scale projections and installations.
I'm gonna leave you with a robotic ape transitioning
from a quadrupedal to a bipedal posture.
And as always - thanks
for watching.